foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar breaking
through rtq PCR boundaries in gene
expression analysis
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderate for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermal Fisher Scientific to
learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send all questions submitted
will be answered via email following the
broadcast you may also submit any
technical issue issues here as well if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Jennifer Sandoval senior manager of
molecular biology at dermo Fisher
Scientific
Jennifer you may now begin your
presentation
thank you to all of you for joining
today to discuss our tqpcr and its
importance in gene expression analysis
before we get into the presentation I
would like to notify everyone that there
will be polling questions that will
appear throughout the talk today as they
appear if you could please take a moment
to answer the brief questions presented
it would be most appreciated
during this webinar we will give a brief
overview of reverse transcription and
reverse transcription qpcr RT qpcr
then we will discuss the attributes of
reverse transcription enzymes that are
critical for successful rtqpcr
experiments the rest of the time will be
dedicated to tips and tricks for
overcoming rtq PCR challenges
particularly the challenges that occur
when working with very difficult RNA
samples
okay so let's get started with the
overview
back to the basics of the different
methods as you know reverse
transcription is basically the synthesis
of cdna using RNA as a template the
figure here shown highlights the reverse
transcription process in yellow to
identify where it fits in the flow of
genetic information
in nature reverse transcription is
involved in a number of processes in
different organisms the most well-known
of the processes is the propagation of
retroviruses in fact most of the reverse
transcription enzymes that you use in
the lab originated from these
retroviruses
besides those reverse transcription also
plays a major role in retrotransposon
migration as well as telomeric extension
during cell proliferation in new
carriers
of course this is also found in bacteria
during synthesis of multi-copy
single-stranded DNA so really a variety
of processes in a variety of organisms
are regulated by reverse transcription
reverse transcription is also being
utilized for many different types of
applications for example in rtq PCR
reverse transcription is combined with
quantitative PCR to measure gene
expression in addition rtq PCR can be
used to characterize different RNA
species such as transcript variants long
non-coding rnas micro rnas and so on
rtq PCR is also used to detect RNA
viruses like influenza zika and of
course coronaviruses and in some
instances Amplified qpcr fragments might
also be used for Downstream cloning
applications and further analysis
for the purpose of today's talk we will
focus on the rtqpcr workflow which
involves five main steps first we begin
with our samples these can come from a
variety of sources but for this purpose
let's say the samples are cells or or
tissues
once the samples have been collected the
RNA from those samples must be isolated
after isolation reverse transcription of
RNA into cdna occurs the resulting cdna
is now the template for the qpcr step
at the end of this step the resulting
amount of Amplified DNA has been
Quantified at every cycle which
correlates to the levels of gene
expression
by Design the rtq PCR technique is very
sensitive which is useful when
attempting to detect very small
differences in these levels so that very
small variance in gene expression can be
detected
this enhanced sensitivity however also
means that small variants introduced
during the rtqpcr setup or variants that
are introduced during the workflow can
have an effect on the rtq PCR results
which can therefore result in variance
and inaccurate gene expression data
and the initial phases of the workflow
during sample collection and extraction
you might face a number of different
issues like RNA degradation low Purity
and low yield all of which affect rtq
PCR data in Reverse transcription you
might face a number of pitfalls for
instance the R2 reaction might not be
efficient accurate and linear
this often depends on sensitivity
stability and inhibitor tolerance of the
RT enzyme used
variation in pipetting of RT components
can also contribute to inconsistency in
rtq PCR results
and as pointed out in this paper
reference tier on the right hand of the
screen published by Bastian at the team
the quality of reverse transcription
plays a significant role in achieving
high accuracy for rtq PCR results
very commonly poor and inaccurate rtq
PCR data actually arise do us due to a
sub-optimal setup
at the end in the qpcr itself there
might also be issues such as sub-optimal
primer design or outside sensitivity as
well as reaction inhibition
so in order to obtain sensitive and
consistent rtq PCR results you need to
avoid and or overcome these challenges
throughout the experiment
in the webinar today we will highlight
ways to avoid some of these challenges
we will focus on the challenges that are
related to executing reverse
transcription and gene expression
quantification with difficult RNA
samples
before we jump into the rest of the
presentation I wanted to first point out
that as I mentioned before a common
source of variants in the rtqpcr
workflow may arise simply due to issues
with pipetting for RT sets only as you
know we have to pipet a number of
different components RNA templates
primers we need of course dntps buffers
need to be added
RNA Inhibitors are highly recommended to
enclose the reaction and maintain
Integrity of the RNA template then we
need water and finally reverse
transcription enzymes the point here is
that there are many many components of a
reverse transcription reaction
if they're added individually into the
reaction mix errors could be introduced
so to help minimize these errors for rtq
PCR in particular it is highly highly
recommended to use a Master mix that
contains all the cdna synthesis reaction
components in a pre-mixed format
not only will this reduce the variation
in your experiment but it will also
reduce the chance for contamination in
addition to saving you time
looks like it's time for our first
polling question please take a moment to
let us know what type of challenges
you've already faced while performing RT
qpcr in your lab
hopefully that gave you adequate time to
answer and now that that is out of the
way let's turn to important
considerations when choosing reverse
transcriptases
not all reverse transcription reverse
transcription enzymes are the same these
enzymes can vary in a number of
different aspects dependent upon things
like rnas H activity thermal stability
versatility sensitivity inhibitor
tolerance and just overall performance
contrary to what many researchers may
think your choice of RT enzyme can have
a strong impact on your rtq PCR data in
both quality and accuracy
here's one example that demonstrates
this aspect the expression levels of 14
different genes were examined by an rtq
PCR assay using 11 different RT reagents
for each gene rtq PCR was performed with
the same qpcr Minister mix but using 11
different RT reagents
the resulting CT values were normalized
against a CT value of 1 for the
superscript for Velo Master mix which is
shown in red
the other Master mixes that were used
all have a normalized full change of
less than one meaning that they are less
efficient in getting higher CT values
than the superscript products the thing
to observe here is that there are huge
differences in the data among the RT
reagents the efficiency of the master
mixes is all over the Spectrum which
means that the choice of RT reagents for
your experiment has a huge impact on
your CT value which affects your end rtq
PCR results and ultimately your
interpretation of your gene expression
results
so given all of these variables how do
you choose the best reverse
transcription reagent for your rtq PCR
application
it's always best to First consider the
type of RNA sample you are working with
and then follow up with the aspects of
your reverse transcription reagent in
the next couple of slides we will
discuss quickly these RT enzyme
attributes and why they are important
first let's take a look at the rnas H
activity of reverse transcriptases
natural or wild type reverse
transcriptases have rnas H activity
which will degrade RNA in the RNA cdna
hybrid this is shown here in the top
figure
when we need to synthesize long cdna
this activity is detrimental because it
can cleave off RNA too early and result
in truncated cdna in addition rnas H
activity May reduce enzyme sufficiency
because it can potentially compete with
polymerase activity
in recent years rnas H minus mutants
have been engineered to reduce or
completely remove rnas H activity this
helps to increase cdna at length but
also it helps to increase overall
robustness and efficiency of the enzyme
so if you have poorly expressed genes
degraded RNA or low amount of RNA
template be sure to choose an rnach
minus enzyme in order to increase your
cdna yields for subsequent qpcr
amplification
another important aspect to consider is
the ability of the enzyme to withstand
high temperatures this is also called
enzyme thermal stability typical
wild-type enzymes work optimally it's
somewhere between 37 and 42 degrees
Celsius
thermostable RT enzymes can work at 50
degrees Celsius or higher so why is that
important
this is especially helpful when your RNA
template contains a very strong
secondary structures or high GC content
these structures will hinder RT enzymes
from binding to your RNA template
therefore reducing overall efficiency
temperatures above 50 degrees Celsius
are recommended in these situations to
help facilitate the separation of these
strong secondary structures of RNA
molecules
highly thermostable reverse
transcriptases can tolerate these higher
temperatures and therefore using one can
increase your cdna yields and give lower
CT values using thermostable enzymes
with elevated temperatures can also help
increase specificity when performing rtq
PCR with Gene specific primers
another important reverse transcription
enzyme property is processivity which is
defined as the number of nucleotides
that are Incorporated by an enzyme
during a single binding event
on the left side of the image we see an
enzyme with very low processivity it
incorporates only a few nucleotides each
time it binds to a template these types
of enzymes are slow and less efficient
luckily there are now engineered enzymes
in the market that have been designed
for higher levels of processivity
resulting in a higher number of
nucleotides being Incorporated during
each binding event as shown on the right
side of the image but why does this
matter
when you are using an enzyme with a
higher level of processivity your
reactions are faster beyond that however
a high level of processivity increases
the Affinity of the enzyme template
therefore enabling the enzyme to produce
a longer cdna synthesis
so the true added benefit of an enzyme
with high processivity is its ability to
read through RNA even when degraded or
even when the RNA sample contains
Inhibitors since the enzyme is more
robust it's highly recommended to make
this selection to ensure accurate and
reliable rtq PCR results when dealing
with degraded or inhibitor-containing
RNA samples
now as we mentioned before RT enzymes
also differ in sensitivity
this factor is especially important to
keep in mind when studying gene
expression of poorly expressed genes or
when working with samples that have low
RNA amounts
with low abundance or very low abundance
targets an RT reagent with poor
efficiency will generate High CT values
or no CT values at all
the blue curves on the graphs here
represent a more efficient enzyme that
has resulted in lower CT values for both
High abundance and low abundance genes
thereby allowing and enabling more
reliable quantifications
in order to detect RNA that is a low
quantity highly sensitive reverse
transcriptases are essential to ensure
the accuracy of the quantification
our final consideration is focused on
inhibitor tolerance many scientists
using RT reagents are often not aware
that reverse transcriptase enzymes are
highly susceptible to inhibition by many
different compounds that can be found in
the RNA preparation steps
even after the RNA purification step
different compounds that can affect RT
enzyme activity can still be present
for example chemicals used in the RNA
isolation process Inhibitors from
biological sources or simple reagents
that are used for preservation of your
samples can all be Inhibitors of your RT
enzyme
some of these Inhibitors are incredibly
difficult to avoid and or remove which
means that they will be present in your
RNA sample regardless of the
purification method selected
therefore it is highly recommended to
use an enzyme that is resistant to these
Inhibitors in order to get reliable
rtqpcr results
later in this webinar we will discuss
these Inhibitors at greater length and
demonstrate the huge differences in the
way that enzymes deal with these
Inhibitors and then the effect that this
has on your rtqpcr results
so now that we have reviewed all of the
different features and considerations of
reverse transcriptase enzymes let's
discuss the best way to choose a reverse
transcriptase enzyme for any given
application
the table displayed here can help with
the decision process there are
essentially three different types of
reverse transcriptases AMV mmlv and
engineered mmlv
AMD RTS were one of the first reverse
transcriptases to be used in the lab
this RT is relatively thermostable but
has very high rnase H activity which
limits its cdna synthesis capability to
five kilobases or less
next up is the MLV enzyme
this has historically been a popular
choice due to its reduced rnas H
activity when compared to AMV RT but
with the target length synthesis ability
of up to seven kilobases
the last option the engineered MML VRT
has been designed for optimal cdna
synthesis there are a large number of
these engineered enzymes available some
of which can produce higher cdna yields
in shorter reaction times with a variety
of sample types also because these
enzymes have reduced rnach activity high
processivity and very high thermal
stability they are an excellent
selection when working with any type of
RNA sample to produce accurate and
reliable rtq PCR results
selection of this type of enzyme is most
critical however when working with
challenging or sub-optimal RNA templates
in order to avoid potential failures of
your reaction based on your enzyme
selection
some examples of this type of sample
would be a subpopulation of cells or
maybe clinical research samples that
have limited RNA amounts working with a
gene of interest that is expressed at a
very low level
genes that are high in GC content or
secondary structure
or when working with samples where RNA
Integrity has not been adequately
preserved like animal tissues blood and
plant samples or samples that have high
presence of Inhibitors such as soil and
ffpe samples
in all of these cases an engineered
mmlvrt would be the recommended enzyme
of choice for sensitivity and efficiency
in the coming slides I will show some
rtq PCR data when working with these
challenging samples and discuss how
highly efficient reverse transcription
reagents can help you to achieve high
quality data
before we get into that let's first
discuss specific ways to overcome rtqpcr
challenges when working with difficult
RNA samples
but first time for another polling
question please let us know if you would
like to be contacted by our team to help
in your selection of products
okay moving on
many reverse transcription reagents can
effectively transcribe highly abundant
RNA targets when analyzing gene
expression from limited sample sources
or when analyzing expression of low
abundant genes however these enzymes
often fall short if you are working with
these challenging types of samples it is
highly recommended to check both the
sensitivity and dynamic range of your RT
reagent and rtq PCR reactions
here we have an example of results from
a high abundance Gene Gap DH and a low
abundance Gene pole e using an rtq PCR
assay with two different RT Master mixes
in both cases we have a linear dynamic
range spanning from one picogram to 2.5
micrograms of total RNA
both Master mixes use superscript for
Velo and superscript Velo provide
detection of RNA down to one picogram
for both genes which demonstrates that
they are both efficient sensitive and
appropriate selections for both high and
low abundance Gene
the superscript for Velo Master mix
however that's shown in red does have
lower CT values meaning that it is more
efficient and provides higher cdna
yields with the same high linearity
across the widest range of RNA inputs
if you are working with small RNA
quantities make sure to test the dynamic
range of your enzymes and ensure that
your setup will effectively work with
your low input RNA sample
when your RNA template is degraded or it
contains Inhibitors selecting RT
reagents that are highly sensitive and
efficient can make a huge difference
and the example shown here we used RNA
isolated from Whole blood which had a
large amount of degradation in the
sample
when we compared rtq PCR data from this
sample using five different cdna
synthesis reagents we found that all of
the reagents used were able to
transcribe RNA from the high abundant
Gene Gap DH which is shown on the left
hand side
on the right hand side however only one
of the five reagents was able to
transcribe the RNA for pole e a low
abundance Gene from The Limited RNA
input sample
as such we can conclude that a highly
efficient reverse transcriptase is
critical for the detection of low
abundance targets when working with
highly degraded samples in which your
RNA input will be at lower levels
if you are working with these types of
limited samples such as isolated
circulating cells stem cells or clinical
or research samples you know that RNA
isolation might not be possible since
this process can and often does result
in the loss of RNA
so what can you do
one possible solution is to use
specialized reagents that allow you to
perform reverse transcription without
RNA purification such as the invitrogen
cells direct cdna synthesis kit with
this kit you can go from cell collection
culture and mammalian cell lysate
directly into cdna synthesis in a single
tube
since RNA isolation and purification is
not necessary loss of your total RNA
sample is prevented which is ideal when
working with low RNA input
another option for low input RNA samples
is the invitrogen superscript 4 single
cell low input cdna preamp kit
this kit provides direct cdna synthesis
and amplification from intact single
cells
the single two protocol is ideal when
trying to utilize minimal bias while
increasing the number of measured
targets from a single sample
because the kit contains the superscript
for RT enzyme it maintains high levels
of sensitivity full-length cdna yields
and is also compatible with Downstream
analysis by NGS or qpcr
okay now let's discuss another RNA
sample challenge RNA with high
structural complexity
as previously stated reverse
transcription has a tendency to be less
efficient when working with RNA that is
rich in secondary structures
these structures can hinder your enzyme
from reading through the RNA template
thus resulting in lower yield and
inconsistent CT values
your inclination may be to run your
reverse transcription reaction at a
higher temperature to release the
secondary structure makes sense
be careful however when doing this
because elevated temperatures can often
denature reverse transcriptases
especially wild-tech natural enzymes
such as AMV or mmlvrts
you can see the need for using RT
enzymes with high thermal stability in
these cases
the data shown here Compares reverse
transcription reactions using
thermostable versus
non-thermostatal enzymes as you can see
at about 55 degrees reverse
transcription efficiency is drastically
reduced when using non-thermostatal
enzymes as seen from the fainter and
missing bands on the right hand gel
now for this kind of RNA it is also
desirable to have highly processive
enzymes so reactions can be carried out
at higher temperatures in a shorter time
in the figure on the right reverse
transcription using different Master
mixes was performed at various specified
temperatures for 10 minutes the red
circles show results from using the
superscript for velomaster mix which
contains a thermostable and highly
processive RT enzyme which produced more
comparable cdna yields and CT values
across the range of temperatures tested
next let's discuss challenges when
working with RNA from tissue samples
whether you are working with fresh or
archive samples challenges may arise
simply due to the inherent nature of
these tissues or due to the way the
sample was processed in the following
slides I will review helpful tips and
tricks when working with RNA from fresh
frozen ffpe and archived tissue samples
rna's tissue can easily become degraded
during sample collection and handling
as such the question arises is to help
preserve the RNA during tissue handling
one reagent that we have seen to be
helpful in this situation is the
invitrogen RNA later solution
RNA later solution is a tissue storage
reagent that rapidly permeates tissue to
stabilize and protect cellular RNA a
bonus is that it's very easy to use
fresh tissue samples or cells are first
added to the RNA later solution where
RNA can be stored for up to one day at
37 degrees Celsius one week at room temp
or indefinitely at minus 20 degrees
Celsius
when you are ready to proceed with your
experiment simply remove the RNA later
solution and continue with your
extraction procedure
the data shown on the right hand side of
the slide shows the Integrity of RNA
isolated from a variety of tissue types
and stored in the RNA leader solution
for different durations and at different
temperatures
as you can see all of the samples have
successfully preserved the RNA under all
conditions this approach is highly
recommended in circumstances where your
RNA is at risk of degradation during the
sampling process
there's some instances where complete
protection from RNA degradation is just
unavoidable
in these cases if it's always it's
always recommended to use a highly
processive and sensitive RT enzyme to
achieve accurate and reliable results
as an example here we have shown rtqpcr
results using degraded RNA from Frozen
lung tissue samples the Rin for all of
these samples was less than five so
fairly degraded RNA
CT values as before were normalized to
the superscript for Velo Master mix
across the board the different RT
reagents used resulted in very different
efficiencies with this degraded sample
type
highlighted just to again stress the
importance of your RT reagent choice in
order to obtain high quality results
okay now let's take a look at challenges
that are associated with ffpe samples
where RNA often gets degraded due to the
way in which the samples are processed
both during tissue preservation and also
retrieval from the blocks not to mention
the additional complications of low RNA
yield and Inhibitors that are concerned
with ffpe sections
to overcome these challenges make sure
to choose an isolation method or kit
that has been specifically designed for
ffpe samples there are a number of
different kits to select from and the
table shown here highlights the critical
components of each option
each type of Kit differs in things such
as expected yields preparation time the
overall process and compatibilities
selection of the appropriate kit for
your application can help to overcome
the hurdles experienced with these ffpe
samples
in this example a number of different RT
reagents were used for rtq PCR on ffpe
samples you can clearly see that there
is a large range of differences in the
results across three genes b2m Gap DH
and actb
the RT enzyme with a high sensitivity to
detect low amounts of RNA a high
processivity to transcribe fragmented or
degraded RNA and a high inhibitor
tolerance to withstand inhibition from
carryover chemicals into which just
happens to be superscript 4 Velo it far
outperforms the other RT reagents used
as you can see in the red bars on The
graft
let's move on to working with RNA that
is isolated from blood samples
RNA from blood samples is often degraded
due to the elevated amounts of rnas that
are naturally present in blood
the image shown on this slide is looking
at RNA that is extracted from cultured
cells on the left compared to RNA from
Whole blood samples on the right
as you can see the RNA from Whole blood
is heavily degraded and presents a
common set of issues when dealing with
this type of sample
in addition to the degradation RNA yield
may also be low depending on the amount
of blood cells that are available in the
sample for RNA extraction
Inhibitors are also a factor when
working with whole blood mainly due to
the heme anticoagulants or Heparin that
may be present in the RNA
there are a lot of challenges to
overcome when analyzing gene expression
from Whole blood RNA
one way to overcome blood RNA
degradation
examples using RNA stabilization
reagents
these reagents can lice blood cells
while inactivating rnases that are
present during precipitation of the RNA
all of which are important steps to
prevent degradation
one such type of reagent is the applied
biosystems tempus blood RNA tube when
using this product blood is collected in
the tube and mixed with the
stabilization reagents to create a
stable RNA sample that can be stored up
to five days at room temp up to seven
days at 4 degrees Celsius or for longer
storage at -20 degrees Celsius
however in many instances such as when
you are using clinical blood samples for
research collecting blood in RNA
stabilization reagents might not be
possible
when this is the case it is critical to
select a robust enzyme that can handle
the low input and degradation that is
present in your samples
shown again with this example our highly
effective superscript 4 Velo mastermix
which is highlighted in the dashed line
ovals is making a difference this enzyme
is generating not only lower CT values
but also less variation
finally when working with blood samples
Inhibitors and anticoagulants are always
going to be a factor
they are typically present in blood RNA
even after RNA purification using a
variety of methods and as no surprise
different RT enzymes are going to have
different susceptibility to those
inhibitors
here we show how Heparin and human can
inhibit your rtq PCR experiments as you
can see some of the RT reagents used are
more resistant to inhibition than others
analyzing on both whole blood samples as
well as the Inhibitors themselves just a
reminder please select carefully when
deciding on a reverse transcription
reagent to use with these samples
we know that analyzing gene expression
from animal and human tissues can be a
challenge
but with the advances in robust reverse
transcriptases that are available
reliable results are achievable even
when working with challenging sample
types
so let's now turn our Focus to working
with a different template plant samples
plant samples pose unique challenges in
that different types of tissues plant
developmental stages variety of species
and so on may require different RNA
isolation techniques
in addition plant compounds like
polysaccharides phenolics and flavonoids
have been shown to inhibit reverse
transcription enzymes
finally poor RNA Integrity is a common
issue occurring after extraction from
plant samples
the gel shown here is demonstrating the
high levels of RNA degradation that is
commonly observed across a wide variety
of plant tissues
when plant RNA is reversely transcribed
with different reverse transcription
reagents large differences in CT values
and differences in rtq PCR results are
observed
in this example we have tested seven
different reverse transcription reagents
with three different plant RNA sources
to detect six different gene expression
levels no surprise again there is a
large variability in the end results
also considering the effects of
Inhibitors Within These plant direct
extracts we can clearly see that some
enzymes are more resistant than others
in addition you can see here from the
lower CT values that some RT enzymes are
more efficient than others when working
with degraded RNA in these plant samples
the more robust RT reagents also
provided more consistent and reliable
data as shown by the lowered standard
deviation which should provide
confidence in your rtq PCR data when
using these enzymes
okay one more polling question before we
wrap things up please let us know if you
would like to be contacted for quote
assistance we appreciate your
participation
I hope you found all of those tips and
tricks beneficial for rtq PCR analysis
for Animal Human implant tissue RNA
samples for our final consideration
let's take a look at one final common
issue that occurs with the rtq PCR
workflow across almost all of these
sample types genomic DNA contamination
common issues that can arise due to
genomic DNA contamination of isolated
RNA include false positives which lead
to an accurate gene expression results
Trace Amounts of genomic DNA are very
commonly co-purified with RNA even when
using the most optimized RNA isolation
techniques
this gel image is an example of what
genomic DNA contamination might look
like with the upper band being detected
in Lane 4.
although we can see it here please also
keep in mind that in a majority of cases
genomic DNA might not be visible on the
gel due to its low quantity present in
the sample nevertheless since rtq PCR is
a very sensitive technique even small
traces of genomic DNA can lead to false
positive rtq PCR results leading to an
accurate quantification of gene
expression especially if you are
quantifying low abundance genes
a good solution is to use a control
reaction without any reverse
transcriptase to detect any genomic DNA
that might be present this is shown in
green on the graph
here we detect here we see amplification
even without an RT enzyme which clearly
indicates contamination with genomic DNA
another solution is to use Exon Exon
spanning primers in qpcr that are
designed such that genomic DNA
containing the intron cannot be
Amplified
in this case if you have genomic DNA
contamination it will not be Amplified
in your sample thus separating out the
RNA from the DNA
a final option is to treat the RNA
sample with dnase 1 to remove the
genomic DNA however although dnase 1
Cleaves double-stranded DNA which is the
genomic DNA it can also cleave
single-stranded DNA including your
primers or cdna so in order to preserve
the Integrity of your reaction dnase 1
must be completely inactivated and
removed prior to the reverse
transcription step
this inactivation is usually done by
adding EDTA and heating at 65 degrees
Celsius
this step however is quite harsh for
your RNA and might lead to RNA
degradation
since this can have a negative impact on
your rtq PCR results especially when
working with low input RNA samples or
poorly expressed genes you might want to
consider using a modified dnase reagent
like easy dnase
in featured in Easy dnase enzyme has
been designed to be specific for
double-stranded DNA cleavage as such it
will not degrade your single stranded
primers or cdna when in the reverse
transcription reaction
easy dnas can be easily deactivated at
55 degrees Celsius for two minutes if
desired but this step is not necessary
due to the enzymes double-stranded
specificity
if you choose to complete the
inactivation step however because it is
performed at a lower temperature and for
a short time the Integrity of the RNA is
less impacted
the graph here highlights rtqpcr data on
RNA that has been treated with either
easy dnas or with dnase 1 in the
mandatory inactivation
the DNA's one treatment and inactivation
represented by the dark gray dots
resulted in increased CT values when
compared to the easy dnas represented by
the red dots in the rtq PCR assay
that suggests that there was an RNA
degradation present in the DNA's one
treated sample that was not present in
the easy DNA treated sample
using easy dnas to control your genomic
DNA contamination can really help to
streamline and easily preserve the
Integrity of your RNA preparation before
you perform rtq PCR
so just to recap traditional reverse
transcription workflows using dnase 1
are time consuming have removal steps
that can degrade your RNA and often fail
to remove gdna completely which leads to
inaccurate results
easy dnas can be provided in a single
tube with your superscript 4 one step
rtpcr system or the superscript 4 Velo
mastermix for a simple one-tube workflow
wait did you catch that a single tube is
used
in a gentle two minute gdna removal step
and an RT reaction in just 10 minutes
bringing your total time to 27 minutes
versus 105 minutes with the traditional
method very streamlined and completely a
Time Saver for this part of your
experiment
so in research these days we are using
more and more relevant but technically
challenging samples such as blood
samples tissue samples biopsies and
others which often yield low input
degraded and or inhibitor containing RNA
one of the biggest challenges with those
sample types is how to get highly
reliable gene expression data
in all rtqpcr assays but especially in
these circumstances reverse
transcription is a critical step that
needs to be carefully optimized to
ensure reliable and accurate gene
expression interpretation
as we highlighted today not all RT
enzymes are the same differences in
efficiency and reliable performance
become even more exaggerated when
working with sub-optimal RNA
preparations
RT enzyme properties such as rnas H
activity thermostability processivity
sensitivity and inhibitor tolerance can
and will impact the success of reverse
transcription and therefore have to be
carefully considered in your RT enzyme
selection
challenges within RNA samples can range
from low input degradation Inhibitors
and secondary structures
and finally to conclude keep in mind
that only highly efficient Reserve
reverse transcriptases have the ability
to overcome these challenges to generate
high yields low variability and faster
reaction times for all types of RNA
samples
thank you so much for your attention
today I hope that you found this webinar
beneficial and that you learned some
considerations to keep in mind to help
you with your rtq PCR experiments to
learn more about the data and or
products you have seen today please go
to the links provided here for more
information
if you are interested in more reverse
transcription Basics considerations or
additional webinars please visit our
educational and webinar hubs listed and
lastly you may also contact our
technical support team directly using
the contact us information URL that is
listed
thank you for your time and your
attention
thank you Jennifer for your time today
and your presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor dermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions
submitted today and during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye